let's go next to alejandro
from san antonio texas you're on the air
oh oh hello hello hello hello
uh awesome david um it's been about like
two years since
last time i called wow when they come
back thank you i'm so glad to have you
back
so about that you're continuing to do
your show um
i the show has not yet the show has not
yet
failed and collapsed much to the the
chagrin of many in the audience
definitely yeah yeah one day guys just
you wait it will come
right um my question today for you
is is the world gonna get a little bit
more
worse like more worse off like
politically not with covid
necessarily with everything going on in
the east middle east
you're saying is the world going to be
worse off for a while
yeah like i'm not talking about because
right now the focus is
on america with biden being the
president
trump gone like uh the dredge of it
lingering still but really everything
going on
globally seems very terrifying
you know it's kind of it's kind of like
we're sheltered in a way
there's no question about that um i i
the the problem is that there are so
many different
issues uh background issues and acute
issues
uh there are people who would hear your
question and they would say
you know the geopolitics really doesn't
matter if we don't deal with climate if
we don't deal with climate in 10
15 20 25 years we're screwed right that
would be a very macro perspective
someone else might say you know the real
issue is
this push towards right wing nationalism
in the united states and in europe and
to some degree
even in latin america that someone would
focus on that it's such a
on a planet of seven to what are we
close to eight billion people now
with so many macro and micro problems to
deal with
foreign policy the pandemic i don't know
i mean you know the
the stephen pinker approach which has
been much criticized
is a very long-term macro view which is
the percentage of people embroiled in a
war is down
life expectancy is up infant mortality
is down terrorism is down violent crime
is down the number of people living in
abject poverty is down that's the
stephen pinker approach
there's a ton of people who are very
critical of that because they say well
stephen pinker is considering
circumstances today
in the same context the circumstances
200 years ago
we are so much more advanced right now
that our standards
should not be to compare how things are
today to 200 years ago does that make
sense
yes so it's very much perspective and
philosophy based but
taking all of that into consideration
for me
i think that the geopolitical issues
won't be resolved anytime soon the macro
geopolitical issues
but that hopefully we have competent
enough governments to keep them at a low
enough level
that technological progress can continue
that
biomedical research progress can
continue and that we
deal with the climate issue um so i
i would put myself at like a cautious
optimism like 51 to 49 i don't know
it's a small margin thank you yeah my
pleasure thank you for the call it's a
good question i mean
it's a big picture question but
sometimes digging into the big picture
is a good thing
why don't we go next wow there are a lot
of people
hoping to get on today let's go next to
toby from kansas
toby you're on the air
hello yeah you're on the air toby hi
david um
i just had a quick question about if you
have any thoughts of
what was going on in the uk elections
last week
no i have not been following it no you
tell me what's been going on
um well it seems like kierstana has kind
of
ruined the outlook for labor for the
next
couple years what what happened
um well he didn't really have a concrete
manifesto
played out oh sorry i'm losing my uber
right now sorry
you're losing your uber
oh my goodness they left okay wow
what a what a day just a lot of people
very very much embroiled in different
things why don't we go next to
um let's go to marshall from new jersey
marshall you're on the air hi david can
you hear me
i can hear you hey david i just had a
pretty simple question
about uh in a presidential election
scenario
in which we in which we see another
split between the uh
electoral college result and the uh
popular vote result
yes could something like that trigger
enough of a backlash
so that we see a uh speeded up um
abolishing the electoral college no
and you know the reason i say that
marshall is
uh we had that situation in the year
2000 and nothing changed
and then we had that situation again in
uh
now my friend so obviously we had it in
2016. did we have it in between like in
2004 did carrie get more votes now i
don't remember
anyway the point sorry what was that i
think bush i think bush won both
popular and electoral you know in o4
okay yeah the the point is
uh no it's been 20 years this has been
going on
and it doesn't see it listen what for
the for as long as one party benefits
from the system we have and republicans
benefit right now from that
uh they will resist changing it so no
i'm not optimistic that if it
just one more time is going to make it
change nope i don't see it and i still
continue to think that the best
path to effectively eliminating the
electoral college
is the national popular vote interstate
compact where you don't do it via
some change to the constitution just
enough states agree
to give their electors to whoever wins
the popular vote i still see that as the
most direct path
all right david i thank you so much for
taking my call my pleasure marshall from
new jersey great to hear from you
uh i'm going to take a quick break but
don't hang up if you want to talk to me
because i'm going right back to the
phones in a moment
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wrist watch is the
perfect way
to elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my ventura watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy and
five-year warranty they'll give you 15
off everything in their store and free
shipping at davidpakman.com
watch use the coupon code pacman